Let's take a closer look at the methods
we'll use in the My Favorite Movies app.
Here's the documentation for
the movie database.
I've posted a link to this
documentation in the instructor notes.
Scroll down a little
bit here on the left.
This section on the right gives us
a list of all the methods provided
by the API.
I'm going to select Account, and then
go to Account/ID/Favorite right here.
This is a method that we'll be
using in My Favorite Movies.
As you might expect,
this method can be used to add or
remove movies from
an account's favorite list.
You can see we have this information
about the required parameters,
as well as this required
JSON body section.
The JSON body,
also known as the HTTP body.
Is part of an HTTP request that
allows us to pass parameters,
without having to pass them in the URL,
like we've done before.
We'll start using the JSON Body
when we make our first
post request later in this lesson.
For now I want you to focus on
an extremely useful feature of the movie
database's documentation.
If we click this post banner here,
a pane will slide out from the right.
And in this pane,
we can take a look at example request.
This is very much like the API
explorer that we saw with Flickr, so
let's scroll down a little bit.
And it gives us this really
nice boilerplate code,
that we can use to call each
of the methods in the API.
So for this particular example,
we're calling HTTP,
here's the url, for count id favorite.
Notice it has id in red, because you'd
have to substitute in an id value for
the user id.
But if we keep going down,
we can see in a share all session,
these are some classes that we're
familiar with, and this is really nice.
If we continue to scroll to the bottom,
we can see an example response.
And for this particular method,
the response returns a status code and
a stats message, and
if it's successful, it says, the item
slash record was updated successfully.
Before you get started,
I highly recommend just taking
some time with the documentation, and
clicking some of the other methods and
taking a look at their
example responses.
And their example boilerplate code here,
to actually make the network request.
If we look back at the required
parameters section,
we see this parameter called session_id.
What's this parameter all about?
Well, if you do some digging,
you'll find that The Movie Database uses
sessions whenever we want to
write data using the API.
And by write, I'm referring
to the methods that update or
change data that's stored
in the movie database.
So this would include methods like,
account ID favorite,
where we're changing
an account's favorite list.
It might also include methods for
rating a movie.
There's some separate
documentation about sessions,
that's located on the movie database's
main website that I'm looking at now.
I'll post a link for
this in the instructor notes as well.
This page details how to create and
use a session,
and it's associated session id.
Without reading the entire page,
we see that the basic work flow requires
us to create a new request token.
And then we can either do Step 2a or
Step 2b.
Step 2a says,
ask the user permission via the website.
Or we can the user permission via
the API, and then in Step three we
create that session ID that we
just saw in the documentation.
Now, you'll for
Step two, we do have these two different
ways of asking the user for permission.
One uses the website.
And one uses the API.
In this lesson, we're going to use Step
2b, and we're going to ask the user for
permission via the API.
And then in the next lesson
we're going to ask the user for
permission via the website.
So you'll get to look
at both approaches.
Now if you haven't already,
I highly encourage you to go through
this page and read it yourself.
And some of the terms might
not make sense yet, but
start building a mental picture of
the steps required to create a session.
because a session's what we're going to
need to make our first post request, and
actually favorite movies right?
The My Favorite Movies App.
So we'll need to be able to do that.
Before we go on,
let's talk to Travis and
see what he has to say about
authentication and the movie database.